Sweden it seems is finally closer to
joining NATO after hours of frantic
diplomacy
the Turkish president has been blocking
Swedish membership for 15 months and
just hours before arriving here he added
a new condition he told reporters he was
linking Sweden's bid to join NATO to his
own country's long-stalled application
for EU membership
talks between turkey and Sweden went on
for hours at one point there were paused
so president erdogan could have a
meeting with EU council president Sean
Michelle who promised new and enhanced
engagement with Ankara then late in the
evening the NATO Secretary General made
this announcement
I have just had a constructive meeting
with president adoran
and prime minister Christian
I'm glad to announce that as a result
president erdogan has agreed to forward
the accession protocol for Sweden to the
Grand National Assembly as soon as
possible
I'll work closely with the assembly to
ensure ratification
in addition to the eve of summit talks
on Sweden behind the scenes they've been
frantic negotiations on what NATO
leaders should say about President
zelenski's demands that his country be
given a clear and concrete path for it
to join the alliance the recent decision
by the Biden Administration to send
cluster Munitions to Ukraine has also
been the cause of much unease among
allies two-thirds of whom have signed
the international treaty Banning their
use
well let's speak to our diplomatic
editor James bass who joins us now from
Vilnius James as you were just reporting
their Unity is key but I understand it's
not clear if zelenski will show up which
would be quite the statement
we think zelenski will be here that is
the certainly the word from the NATO
Secretary General he had put Rumblings
in there that perhaps he wouldn't show
because he wanted a very clear
commitment from the NATO leaders that
Ukraine will be able to join NATO now he
knows he's not going to get an
invitation he's not going to be invited
to join NATO at this Summit but he
doesn't want it just put on the back
burner he wants a clear path ahead now
this has been a problem for the 31 NATO
allies of course there's also Sweden
which is the 32nd maybe but not yet
joined they have been trying to work on
some agreed language that will go in the
final communique on what to actually say
to Ukraine about its membership now
they've been going back and forth on
those on that language when I was in
Brussels at Thursday and Friday last
week they thought they were very close
but in fact negotiations have continued
they've continued here in Vilnius
they've continued in the last few hours
they've still had meetings but the
latest I'm told is the ambassadors have
come up with what I think is a form of
wording that they think will pass the
test I'm told there might be some eyes
um to to Dot and some T's to cross and
the final decision will actually be made
in the first meeting of the leaders when
they when the leaders meet it's called
the North Atlantic Council that's the
governing body of NATO all 31 Nations
around the table and they will look at
this language that's been written we've
seen various drafts and heard about
various drafts of some of the phrases uh
for example
um sorry Ukraine it's the rightful
places in NATO or Ukraine's future is
with NATO's those are the sort of
phrases that have been there and they
they really care about this exact
language because president zielinski
cares about this exact language I'm also
hearing it's likely that they will skip
part of the normal process a membership
action plan that's rigorous conditions
that you're supposed to go to before you
get NATO membership it looks like
they're going to allow Ukraine a
slightly different path into NATO but I
don't any of these allies think that
Ukraine can join while there is still an
active war going on still James
expansion imminent imminently clearly on
the cards a win here for staltenberg
when it comes to takier
yeah but still works being speaking the
last few minutes
um because everyone is watching this
very very closely exactly what was
agreed what did President erdogan get
from the EU of course NATO says the the
link between uh the membership of the EU
of Tokyo and uh Sweden's membership NATO
are not linked but there were meetings
that took place uh one meeting was
paused for the other meetings to take
place so certainly in terms of the
choreography of the schedule of meetings
they have been linked here in Vilnius he
said in the last few minutes I'm
absolutely confident we've now solved
the main issue that there'll also be
ratification in Turkey I can add a bit
of caution here because they thought
they'd solved the issue a year ago at
the summit that took place in Madrid and
then there were fresh problems at that
stage and as stoltenberg has made clear
ratification still has to take place by
the Turkish Parliament and interestingly
also by the parliament in Hungary
because Hungary said it wasn't going to
ratify until turkey did so um there's
still some steps to go and there's still
I think uh you know potential for some
problems it's also interesting that
we've heard nothing in terms of an
official statement from the Turkish side
at this point our diplomatic editor
James Bay is there at that NATO Summit
for us in Vilnius with all the latest
thank you very much James
well if it does happen the military
Alliance will further bolster its
presence in the Baltic Sea after
Sweden's accession Paul Reese reports
now from the island of gotland on the
Scandinavian nation's year-long
membership bid
the Swedish flag has flown on the walls
of this beat for centuries
symbol of a once war-like nation that
has remained neutral for the past 200
years
that neutrality is now effectively over
after turkey it gave the green light to
Nato membership as politicians and
diplomats arrived in this medieval city
on the island of gotland this month high
on the agenda was what Sweden could
bring to the table as a member of the
military Alliance
what we now start to see actually is the
Contours of a new security architecture
in Europe Sweden is part of that
security architecture and I would argue
that any crack in this system which is
now slowly being formed
is dangerous any antagonist can of
course use this track with that crack
sealed NATO now has a way to dominate
the northern Seas with this Swedish
territory position between Scandinavia
the Baltic states Mainland Europe and
the Russian exclave of kaliningrad
gotland is a key military asset for nato
in the Baltic but the swedes have found
many obstacles blocking their path since
they applied to join the alliance more
than a year ago Sweden's hopes of
joining alongside Finland were dashed
when the Finns became members three
months ago turkey repeatedly said it
could not allow the swedes into NATO
while protests linked to the pkk were
held in Stockholm and while Sweden's
strict freedom of expression laws
allowed demonstrators to burn the Quran
Sweden maintained on Monday that it has
met and will continue to meet turkey's
conditions but has remained firm on
changing its Constitution there is
nothing in the agreement with turkey
that says that we should stop
demonstrations in Sweden turkey wanted
us to
abolish sanctions against export or
military equipment to Turkey this was
done fairly quickly and we have a new
anti-terrorist legislation freedom of
speech is more holy in Sweden than
anything else
so it's difficult to uh
give that message over to Turkey and
Hungary they are Prosecuting pkk people
they haven't extradited anybody yet but
they will probably do so
Sweden once bolstered its campaigns
against Russia and Poland with ships and
treasure that left the port of visby
the Swedish flag will still fly here but
now it could be NATO calling the shots
Paul Reese Al Jazeera gotland Sweden
well to get some reaction out of Tokyo
now let's speak to Russell cerda in
Istanbul Russell what are you hearing
about what finally tipped the balance
here for erdogan
well yesterday just ahead of the NATO
Summit when President was about to fly
to Lithuania for the first time he has
linked turkey's membership to EU with
the Sweden's accession to Nato and that
was quite a new element to be honest a
game changer element and but it was not
clear whether it is a demand whether
it's a condition or just a proposal or a
wish to revive turkey's membership
process and then they have understood
that actually it is a proposal so trying
to encourage the European Union to
revive turkey's membership process and
the sources here the official sources
are telling us that turkey has got some
some concessions such as the
modernization of F-16 fighter jets that
was awaiting the U.S approval the U.S
Congress approval and also some of the
concessions regarding to modernize the
the Customs Union agreement between
turkey and European union and also
European Union to act in a way that will
restrict the movements and the
activities of the pkk sympathizers in
European union and particularly Sweden
and also some of the trade benefits and
with the liberalization for Turkish
citizens to Schengen area none of this
is is is concluded yet however they say
that European union and some major
members of the European Union have
agreed to work in this Direction with
turkey and apparently president erdogan
has seen that as of now sufficient so
that's why based on that after the
Intensive diplomatic efforts between the
American and Turkish authorities the
other NATO major NATO members and the
Turkish authorities president erdon has
decided to given the green light to
facilities accession to Nato and it is
quite a big surprise of these of this
NATO Summit and now we're expecting that
to come the Turkish Parliament for the
rectification soon Russell soda there
for us in Istanbul thank you very much
Russell well for more on this let's
bring in Marwan kabalan he is the
director of policy analysis at the Arab
Center for research and policy studies
here in Dohan joins us now thank you in
our studio my one I'm curious what in
your mind changed erdogan's mind I know
that President Biden gave him a call was
it f-16s that made all the difference
well I think he tried to make the best
out of this bargain from Sweden from the
EU and indeed from the United States
because the U.S was very keen on having
Sweden admitted to the to Nato I think
from Sweden he got
more guarantees that they will actually
crack down on the activities of the pkk
in in Sweden concerning the EU you heard
that he made this link between EU
membership Turkish membership in in the
EU and and Swedish
um membership into NATO but nobody was
really sure about whether he meant that
because
he will not get it he knows that turkey
has been trying for the past four or
five decades actually to have the
membership
in the EU but you know I mean he has not
been successful in that and of course I
think he got the the green light from
the United States actually for having
the the F-16 uh and probably he got some
concessions economic concessions from
the EU so at the end of the day he
managed to get a pretty good to avoid
and avoid a crisis with both the EU and
the United States especially now turkey
is
facing some economic challenges and he
doesn't want any problems with the
United States sure well let me ask you
then about loyalty because I we know
that erdogan has a relatively friendly
relationship with Russian President
Putin I believe Putin's going to visit
next month even this has all been
treated with a fair amount of Suspicion
by other NATO members was this a
necessary show of loyalty I think so he
was flying actually over the past year
since the beginning of the Ukraine war
to strike a balance between his
relationship with Russia because he
needs Russia and Syria you know these
understandings between turkey and Russia
in in Syria and on the other hand he
wants to maintain his relationship his
membership in NATO and his relationship
with the Western with the Western Camp
so I think
he has been so far successful he tried
to give some signals over the past
couple of days actually that he is a
NATO member although he is having good
relationship with President Putin
because he said during weslinski visit
to turkey last week he said that he's
he's supporting Ukraine membership in in
NATO and he freed the as of group
leaders as well that angered somehow the
Kremlin the Kremlin and the President
Putin see he was trying actually to to
have this balance between his
relationship with NATO and and his
friendship with with Britain so very
much The Balancing Act continues
the director of policy analysis at the
Arab Center for research and policy
studies thanks so much for sharing your
expertise with us again thank you for
having me